- All right, cool.
Yeah, so we do have like a bit of a feed here.
You just got a couple options where you can see
like what's popular and the ones you've created.
You can also bookmark bashes.
We also have a couple of chats that I think
we're gonna get a stream chat going just so
if people wanna chat in here during the hackathon
or once they get access,
that should make things a little easier to communicate.
Don't have to hop to Discord and stuff, but yeah.
So bashes is kind of interesting.
I'm sure a lot of you have seen these types
of vibe-coded like apps before.
You know, it's not like super ground breaking on that front,
but I think what's interesting is the whole network side
of it and the way that we can integrate the network
into the outputs like you saw with how we had
the profile pictures and usernames.
That's often like kind of cumbersome
to set that up on your own when you're making your own app.
So it's kind of nice to get like user authentication
for free.
It comes in handy and like almost pretty much
any multiplayer app.
So that's something that I really appreciate about it.
I mean, having like instant access to an audience
is also really cool. It can be kind of hard
to like share your creation sometimes online.
This is like an environment where everybody's making stuff
together and like contributing ideas.
And it's really quick too.
Like you don't have to publish it anywhere.
It's just like instantly available through the agent,
which is super nice.
So the network is great.
We'll continue to add integrations between the apps
that you can make and bash itself.
So I think as more people join and start making things
and we add some more of these integrations
that should start to feel a little bit more unique
and special.
But yeah, so some of the stuff I like to make on here.
I've just like random ideas like stuff I want to see.
Like I was really interested in different types
of displays recently.
So like, I don't know if you know, flipped out displays,
but I was curious about that.
So I made a little bash to explore what you could do
with that, how you could use that display
in like an interesting way.
Little game ideas, like I'm not really a game designer
or developer, but like having access to these tools
kind of makes that possible.
So I made like a little ant game here
and I also like to make little tools.
So this is like image studios, like an image generator
on an infinite canvas, kind of like Figma.
I'll get into some of those in a minute,
but yeah, let's look at some of the other ones.
They also don't need to like, they can be silly.
Like this one from Bobby, I really like,
it's an auto-tetris, so you can even do.
It just auto-plays Tetris.
Chris, did you have something to add?
Yeah, I just shared the link to the FU one, but yeah.
Oh yeah, the FU one, we'll look at that in a minute.
But yeah, I mean, stuff like this, it's just fun.
Like there's nothing to do here, but like, you know,
seeing this, it's like a fun thing to spend a few minutes on.
Maybe it inspires you to like riff on it
and like make your own version of it
or like an idea to like translate it to something else.
And yeah, like we said, it'll go out.
You can make these public or private,
so if it's public, it'll go out to the feed
so everyone can see it and engage with it.
If it's private, you can do like a session
with just with your friends, work on something together,
maybe like start private, once it feels good,
you can like make it public and like let everyone see,
that's something we do a lot.
Chris mentioned, it's called FU and it's from Bobby,
our great creative director, designer and another silly one.
It takes a second for the agents to wake up.
So they because they're running in like their own little machine,
their own little virtual machine,
if they haven't been started in a while, they take a second,
but when they are active, they just come on right away.
Yeah, it's like a 10 second game
that you might play a few times because it's fun.
I might wanna like share the score with your friends.
We have an integration that'll let you share screenshots
out of the app into the chat, which this one could benefit
from for like high score leaderboard stuff.
That's one of those integrations, that's really nice.
Let's see what else here.
Yeah, so those are some fun ones.
I'll just show a couple of these games real quick,
even though it's not like nothing too crazy.
It's kind of fun to see.
Another cool thing is like just scrolling back
through the agent blog, you do have the ability
to like clear the context.
If there's like stuff in there,
you don't wanna share with everyone.
But it's kind of interesting to see
sometimes like the context won't be clear
than you can kind of see like here.
This is this little ant game.
It's kind of like Simant, if you're familiar with that.
And I was running into some issues
where it was rendering strangely.
So I dropped at some images
and I had it work out those issues for me.
But like if you're curious, you know,
how this project got to where it was,
you can kind of like scroll back a bit
and like see what the process was.
Or if you're curious how someone did something,
if they left the transcript up there,
you can read through it.
So yeah, this is just a little kind of retro ant game,
idle clicker sort of thing,
where these ants have a little colony
and they like go looking for food and water
and little spiders will come
and you have to like manage the colony a bit
and you can kind of see the ants
like coming in and out with the food.
You can like draw little like tunnels for them to dig out.
You can see them digging.
Again, there's like cute sounds and stuff.
You can like set there's a,
there's a question just I can answer real quick.
So you can go either way.
There's not a lot of this is like the code driven generation,
not image model generation.
Sometimes there might be an instance
where it wants to do like an image generator, whatever,
but you can add your own assets.
I'll give you an example.
So someone made a or a pet using their own art,
which actually I think is like kind of the most powerful
flow there is, which is basically,
yeah, so she drew all these like kind of sprites herself
to my knowledge and then would copy them in
and then was loading them into the kind of editor.
So yeah, you can kind of do whichever way you want.
A lot of times it'll start just by the nature of code gen
by filling in some placeholder art via like vector art
like code driven art.
Not the same as like, you know,
generative image models or anything like that,
but you can use those if you want.
- Well, yeah, a couple more things.
Another like, again, nothing like groundbreaking here,
but interesting to me, really into Balattro recently
and I like the shaders were cool.
I was like, here's how that was done.
So I like made like my own little solitary version of it.
And it's just kind of like a fun place to experiment
and try ideas.
So that was a fun one.
And then, yeah, last one I'll share here real quick
is this kind of a more advanced version.
But I mentioned this earlier, which it's like,
I do a lot of image generation and editing
and I also have a background in design.
So I'm in Figma a lot.
I really love the infinite canvas surface.
And I wanted a place like that for making images.
So I built this like little tool.
This is kind of interesting because it generates images
which requires credits, it requires tokens.
So I actually like integrated it.
This again, this is advanced but I integrated it
with the same token pool that or credit pool
that the agent uses.
So you can create images and it'll draw down
the credit balance in here.
So, you know, potentially we could, you know,
build out those features more in the future
to make it easier so people could do that.
But yeah, so like you saw some of the bashes
have custom thumbnails.
So, you know, I was working through some ideas
for like the image studio thumbnails here.
It kind of like this app keeps track
of like reference images and the prompt I use to make them.
It's kind of nice because you can like generate
four at a time, sometimes like these models are really good
but you might need to do a couple generations
to like get a good output.
I set up some prefixes so you could use this
to make like thumbnails and icons
and like user banner for your bash profile picture banner
or the like the bash you're making.
You can make your own little custom thumbnail with it.
And yeah, like kind of just use this
as a playground to work through some ideas.
If you did want to use image end,
there's a few tricks to get it to do that
but you have to explicitly ask for it.
So, most bashes right now do not use image gen.
But like with the thing that Scott just showed,
a lot of times like the thumbnail
that you're having for your bash session,
you want it to be like a little more inviting, you know.
So like as an example, if I like kind of scroll through here,
some of them have cool kind of thumbnails, some don't.
Maybe you want to generate thumbnail.
You can go into Scots and kind of generate that
or maybe you want to draw on yourself.
It's up to you.
No judgment kind of either way.
Shrews, what are the limitations?
What is it?
Is there a size limitation right now?
I mean, you can do 10 files at once, I know that.
- I think we let you upload one gigabyte per like batch
but the space itself won't be limited.
I mean, practically I think it might tap out
like a hundred gigs or something
but yeah, you can upload a lot to it.
- Oh yeah, wait, we got to do two more.
Sorry, there's two more we have to do.
So there's this one, which is kind of cool.
It's an example of like a network on top of the network.
So this is people generating tiny, tiny games
as a social network that was made on top of bash.
And so you can kind of see like,
that's when it starts to get like inception,
like network inside of network.
You can go to the editor.
You can describe the game you want, pixels,
kind of stuff like that and then you can post it.
And then actually we should use this
'cause this is what we're going to use for the,
so what we're going to use for the raffle.
And then we start the race, you know, you get a little bit up.
And now we see all our PFR usernames over the marbles
and hopefully, well, I definitely lost.
How did that happen?
And what do we have Mallory as the winner?
There's, okay, so those are the two winners.
Really excited to meet all your own person and stuff.
And again, there's space for 90 people.
We've overbooked the event just in case people drop off.
So arrive early 'cause there is a chance
it might fill up even if you are approved.
And invite details will be going on and stuff like that.
Okay, great, awesome.
All right, thanks everyone.
Bye.